yesterday rob and you and i spent a lot
of time on they call me baba bowie the
10th anniversary of gary's book
i thought about that all day wow yeah
gary became a list guy for a while i
don't know i think he
around the time of that book he was
really into lists
and i don't know i've been in the list
my whole life yeah oh my god
i have the origin story of how gary got
into lists
this is oh yeah and i was listening to
this last night and this
is insane every year during the last two
weeks of the year
wabc would do a top 100 countdown only
it would play the songs all out of order
the dj would play number 50 then number
72. that was the hook to make you listen
you could send in a self-addressed
stamped envelope when the two weeks were
up if you wanted the whole list in order
but in the chevy impala on the way to
that vacation in 1970
the year the carpenters close to you
became a massive hit
steven showed me a different way to keep
track he bought a composition notebook
and before we left the house listed the
numbers 1 to 100 in the margins
of the first few pages for the next two
and a half hours we listened to wabc
intently filling in all the songs as we
went along we never finished it
sorry this isn't a capra movie but it
did teach me new ways to obsess over
music
wabc i used to listen to wc if you
wanted the list
they would mail it to you they'd give it
to you yeah they would give you the list
he sat in a car for two and a half hours
writing his own list lis what is with
the
who would do that and who what is the
name of the guy who taught him that
he's just gonna say who the hell went
along with this with him
my brother your brother right oh your
brother and
and he acts like he got taught like how
to play chess or something he's like
you're not going to believe this this
guy figured out how
stephen told me how to make lists you
know
you know gary's brother must have hated
him because he said what can i do to
this little [ __ ]
to waste to waste more of his life hey
maybe it was a way to shut me up now
that you're saying it what do i know
we're gonna call i mean three hours
and then when you were done with the
list what would you do with it and just
go in a drawer
it never got finished as i said it never
got finished did you send away for the
actual list of all the top
songs you did yeah would you glue
the list into your book of lists no
would you every year take out the same
loose leaf book
to make your lists or was it just for
that one year
no i mean i mean i did it for several
years i don't know that it was the same
book but it was not one year
why not buy one book keep these things
howard they meant
nothing to him they met enough for me to
put it in a book robin
would you i mean it's unbelievable
would you ever consider writing a book
of just a list
i wanted to just list yeah don't laugh
so for some reason i'm obsessed with
this whole list thing i'm not even
joking around
and there's two books called the book of
rock lists of the book of more rock
lists that i used to read
all the time and when i started pitching
the book
right with that that this book was i was
pitching this like baba bowie's book of
musical lists
and my book agent goes yeah nobody gives
a [ __ ] about that what's your story
what what list are you working on now
are there lists in your head like
musicians have music no no it's not
yeah i've seen i'm seeing a list on the
ceiling while i sleep robin
and the lists are moving around
here's gary puppet are you making a list
i'm compiling a new list
the top 10 ways to waste time number one
writing lists